all right
we're now live for this uh next ama
for month of february so
i'm a little bit under the weather as
some of you probably know from social
media
i have been for about a week or so
and um so we'll see how long i can go
with this
my throat is a bit sore and i'm a bit
prone to
coughing but you know got plenty of
water here so there's a lot of questions
already lined up
let me remind people that um
you know i generally take one question
per person
um you don't need to put the question
multiple times i try to spread it out as
much as i can
so that people can you know as many
people as possible can participate
all right so the first question this is
kind of an interesting jumping off point
from godward is heraclitus logos related
to john the evangelist logos and how
well nobody knows
because we john the evangelist may or
may not have written the gospel
you know um and it's certainly
influenced quite a bit by
the philosophical milieu of the time
i think if if uh you would be much
better
off saying is john is john the
evangelist
or the fourth gospel the referenced
logo is that um related to
logos in stoicism or in platonism
than heraclitus because we only have
fragments of heraclitus
people love to speculate about that and
go way beyond what what's actually being
said there in the fragments and we we do
know
much more about the use of this term
logos
in later philosophers who are systematic
so i would not try to connect
the references to you know enjo arcane
logos all that sort of stuff in the
beginning of the
john's gospel um to heraclitus
i would i would say it's probably if it
is connected to heraclitus it's
to heraclitus through later
authors um it's a very common term means
a lot of different things in greek
so i wouldn't i wouldn't read too much
into it and
it's better to say um
they're using a similar vocabulary
there's
probably similar themes but
is you know is there a real relation or
connection
it's part of the culture it's part of
the intellectual culture
all right matthew asks could i talk a
little on what john locke means by
relations
of ideas i'm understanding it as the
mind's ability to sort its ideas
and say a is a a is not
b uh a has these qualities prior to
being able to
form a subject predicate proposition
i'm a totally self-guided people of
philosophy often find myself on the edge
of understanding concepts
i mean this is something that you find
in the empiricist literature in general
the difference between like impressions
or whatever we want to call them the
things that are coming
in to us from the outside and
giving us you could say raw material
that we're then
using i mean this is you don't have to
be an empiricist you could talk about
the stoic fontasia as an example of this
as well
going back into ancient philosophy and
then we have
um the relations of ideas in our mind we
have things that we can conceptualize or
whatever vocabulary you want to use
we've got them in our mind we can
operate on them and produce new ideas
as a result i think this ideas talk is
often very
um confusing for people reading the
empiricists
even when we get to hume who's going to
make a strong distinction between ideas
and impressions
when you get down to it what's the real
difference uh strength you know ability
to manipulate them
all those sorts of things so the mind
you know
um for empiricist isn't just a blank
slate that
that sort of textbook explanation
is actually misleading the the mind is
not a blank slate except insofar as the
slate is something that can actually
manipulate the stuff within the slate
and work upon them and combine them and
and all of those sorts of
operations right and then the mind can
also scrutinize
its own ideas and see you know how it
wants to classify them or what their
connections are with each other can
compare them
by the way you don't have to be locked
to say this hobbs is saying something
kind of similar in
the first part of leviathan wasn't he so
that's probably enough about about that
part
uh colomous any thoughts on thomas reid
interesting guy i haven't read him for a
long time um
so no i don't really have any
particularly interesting
thoughts on on thomas reid that i think
would be helpful for
for any of you um
johann says can you please explain the
maurice blondel's understand god i don't
understand
well so there's no brief explanation for
race blown bells
you have god any more than there is of
thomas aquinas's view of god or
you know descartes view of god or
hegel's view of god right that's that's
not a
simple topic to talk about but i think a
good way to
go into this would be the talking about
imminence and transcendence and this is
not unique to blondel this is common
language used in philosophy of religion
so god is conceived of is imminent when
god is connected with the world
god is connected with you know the
created world and it interacts with it
in some way right
how exactly that happens well it depends
on which author you're you're talking
about
um and then transcendent means that god
is beyond
the world and typically for theists um
god is conceived as as being both
imminent and
transcendent at the same time actually
not even at the same time because god
doesn't exist in time right time exists
in god
to use anselm's formulation of this in
on truth
um so
you know blondel conceives of god as
having revealed god you know to human
beings throughout history and
you know he's a fairly typical theist
right but he
what blondel's project is is saying
modern philosophy has sort of upset the
apple cart you're not going to be able
to put it back together just by
reaffirming
you know uh some sort of bastardized
version of tomism
that you've managed to cobble together
in the 20th century from bits and pieces
of whatever you were interested in
before
if there's going to be a viable uh
christian
philosophy an approach to things it's
going to have to take into account what
modern philosophy
has you know advanced put on the table
uh what challenges it's raised and then
it can it can respond
in turn so maybe it's a mystic it may be
augustinian it may be
something totally different but it's
going to ultimately
lead us into not just cognizing god but
some sort
of relation with god and through
through a community i mean blondel is a
catholic in the best sense of the term
uh you can say where it's not just some
narrow
cultish kind of thing but but conceived
as a general in the user
universal community um you know
spread through space and time um
so i mean that that's probably enough
uh to say about it there um
did i miss oh here we go yeah joseph
also asked could you explain
blondel's notion of truth in his later
works
did it change any compared to lacio did
it change
no did it expand yes um blondel
in his early works was within a
sort of polemical um situation you could
say where
people were throwing around charges of
modernism very easily
uh often you know quite quite
maliciously
and um you know there was this like
insistence
at the time on something like the
correspondence theory of truth
that you see with with alt writers today
who are like
oh you know post-modernists are
rejecting the correspondence theory of
truth and if you know anything about the
correspondence theory of truth it's just
one of many theories of truth
it's not a single thing like that but
there were a lot of people who wanted to
conceive of
truth as you know adequation between
uh either language and and ma or mind
and the things themselves out there
right and
that works for certain things it's also
a non-starter for so many other types of
truth you know this is why pragmatism
was insisting on something this is why
kierkegaard could talk about truth is
subjectivity this is why anselm back in
the middle ages
by the way if you want to know about
thomas's views on truth you're going to
see anselm
come up an awful lot thought that truth
doesn't just exist in the mind
or in language but in the will and in
action
and in the very you know foundation of
things we have heidegger's
truth is blondel is trying to
do justice to not not necessarily
mentioning say heidegger or something
like that but to a much broader
conception of truth
where it takes into account the fact
that we are truth-seeking beings i mean
alastair mcintyre's conception of truth
as you can find in his his stuff
or gabriel marcels are are compatible
with with blown downs let's call it a
more expansive conception of truth right
um does that change in his later works
no it just gets expanded
and it gets sort of de-polemicized in a
way
as blondel you know spends more time
uh reading and teaching thomas he was by
the way as one of the first people to
actually teach thomas aquinas
in the french academy doing so before
jose uh in his classes
and um you know it's
it's uh the later works hardly anyone
reads them because you know they're
massive i don't know if i've got them
near nearby but
the trilogy is five volumes right
of thick stuff that he dictated while
merely blind
um so if you're going to wade your way
through that
untranslated stuff you're going to find
some really interesting
uh stuff to work with but i mean
is that different than the early blown
deal only if you've got sort of a
reductive conception of the early blown
dell i think
um because you know lakshyong and the
letter on apologetics and um you know
the carnet
on team you know his notebooks um show
him already engaging with something like
that
all right uh here's a more
or less less theoretical more down to
earth
kind of question about um
about the channel when is the next
sadler's caption contest i really enjoy
them from josh um
i have to come up with a good picture um
been sick the last week so i have i'm a
little bit behind on stuff
probably sometime later this month
you know i'll put up a good picture and
we'll see what happens
all right back to theory stuff dylan
vera i've heard many people say
that post-modernism is just
epistemological relativism i know it's
wrong but i'd like to know if you have
any thoughts on why people think that
we even had teachers say that so
there's a lot of thoughts yeah the
even-hand teachers say that
teachers are not particularly you know
uh as a class are not better than
everybody else i mean
i look at my peers and i see you know
the
the nonsense that some of them have been
willing to put forward as good
philosophy
and some of the stuff that they tell
their students in classes
and i'm like oh it's too bad you got
stuck with that person
um so i wouldn't you know overly worry
about the fact that teachers are saying
that
there's there's really and this this
doesn't just go for philosophers this
goes for
pretty much any professor whether
they're in business economics
engineering
there's nothing that's that's stupid
that some professor isn't saying
somewhere
right but on the other hand there's
nothing
stupid like that that some media person
or some ordinary person on the street
isn't isn't saying
like that either so so there's that um
i would you know anytime that somebody
uses the word just with postmodernism
i kind of tune them out because at that
point i'm like well they don't know what
they're talking about because
postmodernism
is a word that means a lot of different
things in a lot of different discourses
it doesn't mean the same thing in
architecture
as it does in say the musical field
as it does in philosophy and it's a word
that's been
you know thrown around since the 70s
right
so anybody it's sort of like
existentialism anybody who's like
well existentialism is just this you're
like well
you clearly haven't done enough work on
this
to be able to say anything and you
probably got that from some you know
bubble gum rapper
summary of it you know when people are
like well you know existentialism
is just the stance that uh existence
precedes essence you're like well no
there's more to existentialism than just
john
paul sartre's characterization of it
which most of the other
you know existentialists at the time
rejected um
you don't want to just go with that so
when people are saying that it's just
epistemological relativism that's just
silly
i mean that means that they haven't they
haven't done their work what should your
response be
i mean you've got a lot of different
possibilities you could tune them out as
somebody who's
you know got an ideological axe to grind
and is trying to like you know
take up your valuable time and headspace
with their [ __ ]
you could try to engage them in
discussion and find out what they
actually think
post-modernism is and where they got
their ideas from
whether it's from any of the crappy
books out there
that are you know anti-post-modernism
but but are doing straw men
with that or whether they
read it on a website or heard about it
on somebody's podcast or something like
that
i mean there's a lot of different things
you can do i would say you know don't
let it get to you
but you have a choice about what you
want to do and i'm going to say
something
that's not just about this topic but
about other things some of me some of
you may have read my essay
in medium don't give them time where i
say that
your time is valuable and you don't have
to debate anybody you don't have to feel
like you have to educate people about
you know where they're they're getting
things wrong
particularly if they're operating in bad
faith and i think this is one of those
topics where that actually
does come up a lot if you want to get
engaged with them you can
um if you think it's it's cool you know
it's a good use of your time to try to
help them out if you don't want to
that's
it's not it's not like you have an
epistemological duty to
make sure everybody else you know
understands
terms and concepts correctly you know
um we live in a time this is the last
thing i'll say about it we live in a
time where a lot of people
love to use terms like that because it
it
you know they've got simplistic views of
the world
and of where they fit into it and
it's nice to have a good boogie man to
identify as
the threat as the bad guy as what's
undermining things
unfortunately the way the world works
and the way human beings work
is way way more complicated than that
and it's not as if you can just like
strip away the bad ideas
and then everything falls into place but
i think a lot of people are
quite attracted to to that sort of
perspective let's call it
all right let's see what else we have
um
just skipped a little bit um
where did it go
trying to scream scroll back up uh
well there's a lot of questions that's
good um
ah here we go omar
asks on average how much time does one
need to read and understand hegel's
phenomenology
and science of logic your lifetime
i mean this is this is sort of a
category mistake question
there is no average time um and you have
to specify what it means to
understand either of those works i mean
i've been
reading the phenomenology off and on
um what would it be like 1997.
uh read in you know english translations
in a french translation by elite and in
german
um and i've taught it a number of times
and i'm still you know when i go through
it again
there'll be things where i'm like oh now
i understand this
better it's not as if there's a measure
for understanding right
and i don't read the science of logic as
often but you know when i do dip my toes
into it
um that's you know
the same sort of thing there there's
there isn't any measure of time
um and there couldn't be not just
because of the nature of the work but
also because of the nature of the reader
right some people would need more time
some people would need less time if
there even was a measure of what
constitutes
understanding it that we could we could
meet so and i think you can say this
about really any other
philosophical works if you want to um so
it's a good question
it's a good question in part because it
reveals
uh something that we don't want to fall
into
this this concern about like i mean
here's here's a way you could
reformulate it if i want to develop
some understanding of hegel's
phenomenology of logic
how much time do you think i should
devote to it per week
right and there i could say well
you know you probably want if you're in
a course of study you need to be
devoting
probably at least three hours at a time
you know to it it depends on how fast
you want to make progress
and how you want to build things i mean
the more time that you can devote to it
probably the better although there's
probably a law of diminishing returns if
you're spending 40 hours a week
reading hegel um that's that's probably
not going to be as beneficial to you so
it's not like doubling 20 hours a week
or quadrupling 40 hours
10 10 hours a week right
even 10 hours a week is a lot to devote
to something so
all right james says why did heidegger
say that nietzsche
was the last metaphysician and
that's a good question so
obviously nietzsche is not the last
metaphysician because people have been
doing metaphysics after nietzsche right
so we have to think about what heidegger
means by
metaphysics and heidegger you could say
thinks that nietzsche is um the
the latest person to give a
new take on on metaphysics by
centering things around the will to
power um
you know i think that heidegger would
say that a lot of people have been doing
metaphysics after nietzsche
although they're doing you know temporal
temporally
after nietzsche they're not actually
contributing something new to the to the
to the picture
i mean heidegger could have called
himself in this respect the last
metaphysician though couldn't be um
but he thought that nietzsche was was um
you know he was doing something very
interesting and
novel even though he's also an
anti-metaphysician that is he's tearing
down
or criticizing the metaphysics of plato
of aristotle of christianity of
descartes
of hegel so
um cosmic hobo is going to be
disappointed i'd be interested in
hearing any thoughts you have about the
work of pure
board you haven't read board you since
graduate school um
frankly i never found him very
interesting to read
it was always kind of dry for me
i remember there there being quite a few
people who were excited about bordeaux
at the time but i don't remember exactly
what they're
excited about so he's just not somebody
who i
who i do any any work on
chris says it seems that art has a lot
of philosophical significance how do
artists come to present truly meaningful
ideas when uneducated in philosophy
whence comes this wisdom and should we
take it seriously so i think when you
when you actually look at a lot of
classic artists you're going to find
that they actually did
did know some philosophy great example
of this is edward munch i'm going to
post something about
from lapham quarterly later on today in
my social media
um the scream is deeply informed by
kierkegaard
right um but you wouldn't know that if
you unless you knew his biography
um and so you know we got to be careful
about that right
um philosophy is not something where you
have the ideas and they're encapsulated
and then
only after you've like you know put the
capsules into your brain like a bunch of
chips
now you can operate with them um you
know it's continually engaged with life
so why wouldn't artists arrive at some
things that
you know require them to engage in some
complex reasoning and
do philosophy in the process and arrive
at interesting
ideas on on the way um
i don't know that we we have to elevate
that to the level of
wisdom um and we have to we have to ask
what what truly meaningful ideas are
they presenting and what medium are they
presenting them into
all right andre are you planning some
core concept videos on chopin hours
famous works or essays maybe
yeah down the line um
i've got some thumbnails actually
created for them
uh for from a while back when i was
hoping to get to
shooting some schopenhauer for one of my
my ethics classes and
you know it's just a matter of finding
the time
and uh slotting it in it'd get done
so i know a lot of people are eager to
have schopenhauer and schopenhauer's a
cool
author a lot of fun to read frankly
right
um but i don't know exactly when it will
be
oh there's alfonzo so alfonso says i'm
at work
busting out dishes just stopping by to
say hi alfonso is a longtime
correspondent
glad to see you here by the way um
if you he's on twitter and uh
and facebook as well uh and does does
quite a lot of interesting
sort of micro blogging speculative
stuff engaging with a lot of
contemporary um
philosophy so you might want to check
alfonso williams out
native clay asks how how am i i'm sick
you know fortunately my so my wife and i
we started like getting ill uh
last week and by by thursday i
was it thursday no friday i started
canceling
uh appointments right and
no it was thursday thursday this week
yeah see
everything gets a little bit loopy when
you're when you're sick and tired
and so you know we had a lot of symptoms
you know and i was like yeah it's
probably a flu or something like that
and um i ended up canceling my classes
for the week and canceling some of my
appointments for the week
um and and doing a lot of like doing a
bit of work and then being really tired
and going
down and taking a nap and then waking up
two hours later and then getting back to
work and
so anyway long story short my wife who's
not a worrier
by the way was like you know we probably
need to go get covid tested because
a lot of the symptoms that we both got
are kind of lining up with this
so we went and got covert tested and got
our results back
earlier this week and we don't have
coved we don't have influence a and b
so we don't know what it is got a sore
throat you know kind of kind of tired
joint ache stuff like that but it's not
covid so that's good
so you know i'm trying to catch up on
work
um i haven't been exercising
obviously um and and you know we've just
been kind of taking it easy
but you know things are going okay um my
daughter
my oldest daughter's up here now at
school
so i'm happy about that i'll get to see
her once i'm better
and that's about it yeah
here's an interesting one from rt whitby
if you were to rate spinoza as a
philosopher from one to ten what would
you rate him and why do you think he's
an overrated philosopher
i think he's an overrated philosopher by
people who don't
really read his stuff but they
kind of they're kind of into what we can
call the spinoza mystique you know
there's
very often there's like a mystique
surrounding philosophers hegel is a
great example like this too i mean
people are constantly memeing about
hegel and talking about like
hegel you know doing this and that and
you're like i don't think you've
actually read much hegel you know
um so there's there's that and now does
that make
a philosopher overrated
i guess so except that you know we don't
have to pay attention to the people that
that haven't really engaged with with
the the thinker right
um we should look at the people who
spend a lot of time with the thinker and
see what they make of them
um i mean i'd rate spinoza about a six
you know i'm not like super in love with
the geometric method
that he uses in the ethics he has
interesting things to say
but sometimes he's you know plagiarizing
them from hobbs
and like you know um not in the ethics
but in the
theolo the tractatus theological
politics
um and you know it's um
it's good stuff uh principles of
cartesian philosophy is kind of
interesting to take a look at
see what he's doing with it um
i just you know i i've never found him
to be
as interesting as some some other
thinkers i mean i i
i if yeah it's like spinoza or
descartes i'm taking descartes you know
um
a lot of people were really into him i
think he was he was kind of a breath of
fresh air for
quite a few people um so you know
there's that
i don't know that i would actually like
want to try to live as a spanosian
um but you know that's kind of an
interesting thing for people to try out
mason says which philosophers do you
find
have compelling insights into how the
will works what do you think they get
right
well a lot of people i mean that's
that's one of the areas that i do a lot
of
work in uh and some of canterbury
obviously you know i mean
i've written probably one one or
probably about
two two-fifths of my
scholarly work um in terms of like book
chapters and articles is on anselm and a
lot of it has to do with
his understanding of the will um
i'm going to be actually presenting
something on that at the upcoming saint
anselm conference
in at college which is going to be done
virtually coming up in april
um you know epictetus
uh although it's not the will there it's
probably racist
which is kind of the will but kind of
not exactly it
aristotle obviously has to talk has some
things to say about prohibi racist but
it's in a weaker sense
than epictetus
the other stoics kind of get into this
stuff you know you see seneca
circling around it um
augustine obviously is an important
person as is boethius
aquinas has some interesting stuff to
say about it but i think he gets gets
quite a few things
off base and it's a major issue
throughout uh
modern philosophy right so you know if
you look at descartes
and you're not just looking for like
what does he think we can be absolutely
certain about but you pay attention in
meditation for to his discussion of the
will
or you know you look at um his his you
know clarifications about it in other
works
there's a lot of interesting things
going on there so
yeah i mean there's a lot of you know
there's a lot of interesting
people throughout the history of
philosophy um
and it's uh here's the other thing i'll
say about free will
there a lot of people are like oh free
will doesn't exist and whenever they say
that
and you ask them well what do you mean
by free will it's always this like big
blown up conception
where it's like totally abstract and you
know it means like we can do anything
that we want at any time you know
and that's that's just not the way that
people generally
the good theorists talk about about the
will you know
it's much more complicated
all right holo says what's the point of
formal epistemology
ie epistemic logic
i don't know i'm not sure what what's
meant by
epistemic logic do you mean like
the logic of inference i suppose it
would be to try to clarify
how we arrive at at uh well-founded
inferences and strip away ones that
that aren't quite so good um
pessi what are the most significant
differences between sarts existentialism
and camus absurdism well kamu doesn't
call his his philosophy absurdism he
calls it philosophy of the absurd
which is different than what other
people are calling absurdism
and i would say there's there's not a
lot of uh
difference between the two except that
um
sartre i think holds people at least in
the earlier stuff
and this is also how start differs from
say to bevoir he's much more willing to
like
ascribe total responsibility to subjects
and
less less attuned to how
um the uh the milieu in which they
they they're developing their facticity
puts you know restrictions on on their
freedom
um i think kamu in some respect
was a better guy in his philosophy
i mean they both have a lot of
similarities um
there's this like you know
there isn't any god so a lot of people
want to say that there is
they can go on doing that but they're
they're in some sort of you know
bad faith or mistaken perception so
let's let's ourselves philosophize on
the basis of this
not being the case and see where we
would go if we still
want to hold on to human values
and want to be um
you know want to be consistent with
ourselves right
i would say that uh camus starting
points are in some respect
more dramatic or rhetorical than
than sarts quite often and
i i mean i i think a lot of people are
going to disagree with me on this i i
just think kamu is a
more interesting writer frankly than
than sartre
um oh here's a great music question
um which classic metal bands would you
recommend to a millennial who wants to
explore the classics but doesn't know
where to start
so i would break it into like areas
and and times you want you definitely
want to
explore the early british metal
stuff right so black sabbath deep purple
uriah
ufo right those are those are all quite
important
and you want to look at the bands that
spin out of those like richie
blackmore's rainbow
and you want to look at
you know white snake for example
a gillen had his own band for a while
you know i've done you could go to the
the um classic metal class
videos and you would get kind of a good
background in that stuff
um scorpions
and except out of germany uh both very
important very influential
in you know the scorpions in both the
70s and the 80s
except more in the 80s um
then you've got you know what we what we
typically call
well before we get to the new wave of
british heavy metal let's talk about two
other really important bands that you
should listen to
and that's motorhead actually i'll say
three
motorhead budgie and judas priest all
three
doing really great metal stuff budgies
actually starting in the in the very
early 70s they're a welsh band
um and so there's that and then we get
the new wave of british heavy metal
obviously iron maiden is the most
important of those but you should you
know check out raven
girl school tank
venom early venom stuff
uh saxon uh and def leppard and and not
the you know
hysteria era deaf leopard but the early
stuff that was good
uh and then you know you want to look at
a early american stuff
obviously kiss is is an important band
in there there's the whole
la explosion with like van halen motley
crew rat
quiet riot lizzie borden you've got
you know alice cooper and ted nugent
doing their stuff um if i remember right
both of them coming out of detroit
earlier on
uh now their stuff is sort of like metal
adjacent sort of like
you can say that some of uriah heap or
ufo is
um and you know that that's already a
big catalog to get you going
um and then you know we could talk about
other well wasp is another important
american metal band um and then you can
you know you get into like the thrash
age and you've got like you know
metallic you've got the big four
of course right metallica um
mega death uh slayer and uh
anthrax but there's all sorts of other
interesting uh thrash bands as well and
so
you know this that that's enough to
probably like
get you going on a catalog but i would
suggest um
watching some of those um classic middle
class videos that i've done with scott
truly because we
we get we get pretty deep into the the
weeds with those
salty says slayer is a great start i
wouldn't use slayers to start i
i would say slayer is like way way way
way way way down the line
compared to the stuff that i just
rattled off
um all right let's see what we got
well here's a good question from
impulsive
do you consider platinus important or
useful to study if one wants a good
understanding of platonism
so the the short answer is no
um if the goal is to understand
platonism
like in you know in in plato's own time
no i don't think you have to but
why would you want to deprive yourself
of
studying one of the most important
authors of neoplatonism
what what you know is coming down the
line you wouldn't want to deprive
yourself of reading
platinus any more than you would want to
deprive yourself of reading plutarch a
very important middle platonist right
they're both they're both really
interesting to read
in their own right and what they're
doing with plato
is trying to use plato's dialogues
and some of his concepts to you know do
their own their own thing
uh and there's a lot of like you know
attributing things to the great master
but it's you know it's effectively its
own
um kind of philosophy
uh made of clay says uh in in regards to
reading hegel should i start with
philosophy history or lectures on the
history of philosophy either one it
doesn't matter
i mean read them both a lot of people
you know ask these like do i need to do
this first or this first or this first
usually unless the philosopher's like
come out and said you must go through my
system
in this order you have freedom you can
you can do it however you want to
avarose peripatetic why you have very
arrogant
face um i'll let other people sort of
figure out whether i do or not
but that's kind of a weird thing to come
into a
ama to ask so you might want to
you might want to think about that uh
let's see
let's scroll down all right arafat
rizzaz
riaz says how can i read philosophy at a
very profound level i'm a beginner
um keep at it right i mean if you're a
beginner
that's sort of like saying how can i uh
become a great musician
and like my friend scott truly just pick
up a guitar and do anything i want with
it
well you gotta do what scott did and you
know back in
undergraduate spend all sorts of time
listening
to other people's stuff and soloing over
it and learning how to play it and doing
you know drills uh and practicing
sometimes eight hours a day and then you
eventually get to the
level of facility where you're like at
an intermediate level
and then you start doing even more stuff
and then you spend some time like
playing with you know great
other musicians and finding out what
they do and you know after you put like
20 years in
now you're at a profound level i mean
there's no recipe to get there
right away so
all right
here's a question that i'm not quite
sure what to make of
does the revenge of realities work in
favor of the divinity if it's right can
you give an example so i i don't know
what the revenge of realities
is i mean it sounds kind of like freud's
return of the repressed
um but i i don't know what that that
means zeno asks
a a a question that i can give an answer
to but it's not going to be helpful for
most people
it's sort of like nikes just do it right
how do you memorize philosophical works
and ideas when using them for debate or
a lecture
i don't i i draw upon
sort of like the
what i've managed to store away i don't
use uh
uh memory techniques or anything like
that
um at one time i i could say that i did
but it was basically just like putting
bullet points together and reading
through them and remembering what that
stuff was
i don't use flash cards i don't use any
of that sort of stuff
um so i'm i'm kind of a bad person to
ask about that
you know
and i don't do a lot of philosophical
debates so
you know again i'm not a good one for
that
uh here's an interesting thing uh day
waste
i've chatted with someone who claimed
that stoicism is not a philosophy but a
worldview he said they were
pre-socratics so they're not
pre-socratics they're post-socratics
xeno uh the founder of stoicism actually
studied with
members of three different post-socratic
schools
the um the cynics karates right
stilpo the magarian and polomo
the the platonist right so he's
definitely wrong on that and and you got
to ask well what do you mean
what's the difference between a
philosophy and a world view for you
because and what you're going to find is
this person got that out of some
textbook or a blog or
you know like a podcast and either
they're going to have some sort of
definition which
nobody else really accepts or they're
going to have kind of like made it up on
the spot
so
uh boomer says he's talking about
fukuyama here have you read the end of
the his
end of history and the last man if so
how did you like his explanation of
hegel's dialectics and human history so
you know fukuyama is not a hegel scholar
and he got his hegel stuff basically
through
kojev as far as i remember it's been a
long time since i've read it
and you don't go to khajev for the
straight dope on hegel but you get an
interesting interpretation
of hegel
you know when you when you make
big sweeping claims like that early on
in your career you spend the rest of
your career dodging everybody asking the
questions well
wait a second what do you do now that
history hasn't ended and you can point
to all of his other books that he's
written after that
the poor bastard never gets a break of
people
like reminding him of how he he
claimed that history was basically done
uh
at that point um it's you know it's not
a bad book
actually it's it's it's interesting to
read
obviously it's kind of dated but
it's worth engaging with and i like
fukuyama you know i've read some of his
other stuff
later and and it's you know it's
interesting stuff
um
cinema asks what are some good
refutations of neoplatonic metaphysics
forms the one idealism emanation
i don't know i mean i don't i don't
spend much time looking at refutations
of of things i spend much more time sort
of like exploring them and neoplatonism
is not like a major
field of my my work you know um
particularly the classic you know sort
of
uh neopagan uh platonism that you find
with like platinus or
uh pro-close or people like that um
so i don't know that that's that's an
interesting question i'm not i'm not
even sure why
why you need a reputation of that sort
of stuff
um all right
uh dan the man who's been here quite
often says
i'm in my off here between undergrad and
grad school been going through kant
hegel payne
is there anything else you'd recommend i
do to prepare really nervous i'm not
ready for the challenge okay so
i can address the second part better
than i can address the the first part um
so you're going to grad school for
philosophy you don't you don't have to
be nervous about it
every grad school is going to emphasize
different thinkers and they're going to
like claim that those are the most
important ones and
these other people are left behind like
i remember when i got to southern
illinois
university and i was getting a tour
from one of the older grad students and
he was like so what are you into and i
was like i don't know i've been reading
a lot of sartre lately and marcus and
he's like rakuza nobody reads him
anymore
and i thought to myself even then well
how the hell would you know buddy
obviously somebody reads them because
i'm reading them you know
and as it turned out he was full of crap
you know you're going to meet a lot of
people
who are going to be like oh if you're
not reading this person
you're not really doing philosophy just
just ignore those people
you know most of the time they don't
know what they're talking about
um you can't possibly read everybody
that everybody's interested in talking
about and you don't have to you don't
you don't have to place that burden on
yourself you know it's
you're going to grad school to learn to
to get exposed to things that you
haven't had before
you're not you're not coming into it
having to know everything
and be the whiz kid or anything like
that as a matter of fact most of the
people who i
seen going into grad school and uh you
know admittedly this is
limited experience on my part who were
the whiz kids they all burnt out
even like professors who were like
rising stars at the time you know
they they're now kind of stuck in
dead-end jobs
doing their thing not taken seriously by
a lot of their peers so you don't have
to worry about all that stuff
the fact that you're actually reading
philosophical thinkers
and there are people who are considered
to be you know interesting or important
now pain
people are going to give you a hard time
about that oh he's not a real
philosopher
yeah he is he's just you know he's just
kind of second rate he's not great
like uh who else did you have in here
you know kant and hegel
but he's not stupid either he's
interesting the age of reason is well
worth reading
you know so is common sense and some of
his other stuff
um you don't have to be nervous about
that
if somebody doesn't like the fact that
you're reading somebody screw them
you know it's it's your brain it's your
time you get to read whatever the hell
you want you know
but keep in mind too you're paying for
this you're paying to get to go to grad
school
you don't have to put up with people's
[ __ ] you know uh making you feel bad
because you're not reading
the right texts or something like that
so i don't know i don't know if that pep
talk helps you out but
we'll see um
all right here's one from andrew pizza
and a beer perfect timing hope you're
well sir question could you talk about
socrates self-talk rumination practice
and how to do it
um we don't know what socrates self-talk
rumination practices
if you're talking about like when he
would go into like a trance
all we've got is he went into a trance
and then you know we get a little bit of
maybe what his reasoning process was but
we don't know what was going on with
that um
i mean yeah so i think that's probably
all we can say
uh fizzywig what's the significance of
the split between right and left to
galleonism did this split
leave hegel's philosophy in 20th century
deficient
so no no i didn't leave his philosophy
deficient
um you know the the the right-wing
hegelianism
was basically a kind of sometimes
conservative
sometimes progressive thing that said um
the real is rational you know the
rational is real we need to like you
know keep working and tinkering and
making it more and more rational
um and we can do this through sort of
incremental progress and all that left
againism is like no
we need to like you know take this this
thing from hegel and like blow it up
into something really important and
we'll all use the dialectic although
they they all use the dialectic in
different ways
and you know if you look at the left
hegelians there's nothing a left
hegelian hated more than another left
right marx is a prime example you know
foyer box got it all wrong you know
so um or bruno bauer
you know uh that's that's kind of yeah
and then and then you've also got like
weird spin-offs like um sterner who's
neither a right nor left hegelia and
he's kind of his own thing
there is actually a great essay by
vincent de combe
in a book that i think is called the
barometer of reason
and he talks about left right and dark
hegelianism which is not
an idea that he came up with himself but
i think got from eric
vay and
he actually considers you know people
like nietzsche to
as well as sterner to to fit in if i
remember right it's been a long time
since i've read this essay to fit into
that but
does the split leave leave uh
hegalianism deficient no
i mean and it wasn't really that taken
stuck in by hegelians in other places
you know we've got the british hegelians
what are they right or left
you know we've got the st louis
hegelians what are they you know
i don't know that they fit into either
of those classifications
uh x blue bells i loved your ad doe
lectures what would be a good series of
your lectures to listen to next
um i mean if you're into the ado stuff
and the
philosophy of as a way of life then the
things that preceded it
like the john sellers article um that
would be good
those three videos on that um i mean you
could go to the stuff on
stock philosophy or aristotelianism or
epicureanism because i know talks about
those things a lot i've got playlists
that are pretty easy to
to find on on the main page of the the
um
the website right um
karanam asks will you continue friedrich
nature philosophy series
so i don't know which series you mean if
you're asking am i going to continue
producing videos on nietzsche the answer
is yes as a matter of fact for my class
this semester i need to produce some
core concept videos
on the genealogy of morals because i'm
having my students read that
and i don't want to assign them just
those four big you know one hour long
lecture videos i want to sign them some
shorter stuff
um
if you're asking whether i'm continuing
the existentialism series that those big
lectures are in
maybe down the line when i reach a
certain level of support on patreon
but i'm definitely going to be shooting
more nietzsche so
all right andrew could you recommend
some philosophical poetry
i mean i don't read a lot of poetry but
you know there's
you can read stuff that's in poetic form
or it's also been turned into like prose
so lucretius is the prime example right
um the or the nature of things is a poem
boethius
the consolation of philosophy it's like
interspersed um
poetry and prose um there's obviously
rilka
you know i'm a huge fan of his
but i don't read a lot of poetry for its
own sake so i'm not a really good person
to ask about that
um mr big weekny why does heidegger try
to secularize christian ideas like sin
into something like fallenness
i wouldn't say that's what he's doing
i think he would say that he thinks that
that there's
something there that the christians got
but didn't completely get and now he's
trying to make it
even more clear but if you want to call
it secularizing and you want to like
approach him in that way you can count
on probably only understanding half of
what he's
saying because of the filter you put on
it
heidegger seems to think that throughout
the history of ideas people have been
making great contributions
not just in philosophy but also in
literature theology
history you know and he wants to take
those on and recuperate those
i i don't you know that that's that's
actually doing good work hegel is doing
something similar right
um aleister mcintyre does similar things
in his own time so
i don't like that we we um the question
is
is he getting things right or not you
know um
so uh
lord mozart is asking about secondary
stuff
what's a good intro to german idealism
for someone that's new to philosophy
no idea i don't spend a lot of time on
on secondary lit
or like you know intro to philosophy
stuff i mean i guess
cobblestone he's got a volume on that
but
you know i haven't looked at it for a
very long time
um that'd be friedrich cobblestone
though the jesuit who's has that whole
history of philosophy but
you know i don't spend time on on
secondary work unless i'm
doing very focused stuff
um luke mcrae i'm really enjoying and
appreciating the series on
religion i think that might be referring
to the uh
religion in american culture um
that's that's good that that's like a
class series from a very long time ago
when i was at marist college teaching so
that's good
uh gutter demeron what's what is faith
on my view
faith is a equivocal term that means
multiple things
um i think whenever you read an author
and they're talking about faith you
always gonna
you always want to figure out what do
they actually mean by it because they
don't they don't always mean the same
um some people mean faith to me well
whatever i grew up with and don't want
to think about but want to like spout
you know all
the time like these you know bible
bangers who throw out
proof text verses you know and you're
like wow that's that's really
interesting i didn't realize you'd read
scripture because that sure is held
on to any way in which you behave or
anything else that you say
um but
in other in other people it means
something you know that's a virtue
that has to be cultivated and other
people it means something
that has to display itself in action you
know
there's all these complex meanings to it
sometimes even in like a philosopher
like anselm uses faith in about six
different ways
in his works you know
all right let me see what else we got
here um
hayward says what i think of peter
slaughter slower dick
i haven't read his his work so i i don't
you know
can't really say
um hey lizzy s will you consider making
any videos on spinoza
yeah but down the line you know um you
know it's
he's not a high priority for me um
oh here's a great question from sam in
your teaching experience are millennials
and gen z
significantly lacking in their knowledge
base compared to previous generations
no not at all every generation is
lacking in their knowledge bases
[Music]
every generation has had failures in the
elementary through high school
curriculum
every generation is oblivious to what's
happened before them
every generation you know knows
something about the new technology
but only at a surface level this and
every generation has exceptions
um so i i don't
i think actually too the other thing is
um
putting aside you know obvious
exceptions like where we're talking
about race or stuff like that
the boomers really did have it a lot
easier than than
you know my generation generation x and
in some respect
respects my generation had it easier
than the millennials and the zoomers
and adding all that stress into it and
you know
our crazy political system and kovid and
all that
it's um you know a lot of people
love to complain about the kids but i
don't see
i don't see you know you know i haven't
gotten to the point where i'm like that
friggin new generation
those those kids you know they don't
appreciate how good they've got it i
don't think they've
actually got it that good so you know
and and where they have uh where
advances have been made
thank god they have you know like in in
terms of medicine
or in terms of like getting past some of
our societal
hang-ups at least in more or less you
know enlightened areas of our culture
um we're you know
but we're facing massive challenges so
all right um let's see what else we got
here
western man what are the most
significant advances that heidegger
made on husserl's phenomenology well
number one
not making it boring as hell right i
mean
i did my master's thesis on his role and
there are some people who get excited
about who's troll but
they are uh an interesting type you know
um i actually have done some other
writing on historical too
hostel is not an exciting person to read
um
or teach or think through um
heidegger is but that's that's a sort of
a you know
side thing right um
i mean they're doing different kinds of
phenomenology you you don't go to the
you know the same people for the same
things
um i mean we could say well
what is what does gabriel marcel who's a
contemporary of them or mock shaler what
are they doing
you know that's different from them or
maurice blondell or
henry bergson who by the way are both
doing something just not calling it
phenomenology
they're each doing interesting things
you know um
so i would i really wouldn't talk about
advances on horserolls phenomenology
nick says if i ever commissioned one
video it would be your thoughts on being
philosophically eclectic i found stoic
aristotle and epictetus helpful but i
worry um could be diluting these these
schools
well you know i did do a video a while
back
on on being an eclectic and i said
there's
there's different ways of being an
eclectic right there's like being a
ciceronian
eclectic where you take cicero in a
certain sense as your model
and he his eclecticism comes out of a
school of philosophy the academic
skeptics
of the time um and then there's like the
smorgasbord eclectic who's like oh i
just want a little bit of this and a
little bit of this and a little bit of
this you know
um there's probably like eclectics that
we could say who are like the people
chasing the ever changing banner
in in dante's inferno which i think is
in the ante chamber
you know uh and and they never catch it
but they're always like chasing after
the latest uh
fad and trying to incorporate that so
there's a lot of different ways to be an
eclectic
and i'm happy to revisit it if you
really want me to
but um i um
i think i might have talked about that a
bit in that video
all right let me scroll down a little
bit
um armin says
please estimate the number of books that
you own
i don't know there's thousands right how
many are on the shelves i i'm
how would i even estimate that that's
sort of like when you when descartes
says you know try to picture to yourself
a kilogon right
and and he's like you can't do it you
can
you can cognize it but you can't
actually imagine it
i don't know how many books i've got you
know more than i more than i need
probably is probably a good answer
all right um
foster says do you think kant's changing
of how cognition works with his theory
knowledge beat out humes i i don't even
know what that would mean to beat out
humes you know are you asking do you do
i think
kant has got things more right than hume
did
i don't know it's not something i
usually put them side by side with i
mean
do i think causality is actually like a
category
probably not and probably more human in
that respect
you know um i mean there's a lot to
recommend here
i actually quite like him even though i
disagree with him on a lot of points
um quiet philosophy do you think it's
just as important to monetize your
philosophical work as it is to get a
teaching job
i mean teaching jobs are great if you
can get them tenure-track jobs
are dwindling fast and
largely going to people who were lucky
enough to go to an elite school
or were you know like groomed by by
people who are
in an elite so there's that um
adjuncting if adjuncting is what you do
full time
sucks and is precarious um
we we are in a you know pretty tough
time marquette university which is
just you know blocks from here is firing
full-time professors
and hiring for adjuncts at the same time
um
so you know it's a rough time monetizing
content
um i mean if you can get people to pay
for your content that's that's good
you've got to have good content i think
or
be able to sucker people in i see some
people doing that in the
world of popular philosophy and there's
lots of ways to do it
um but you know you've got to have
something to
you got to have something that people
want from you right i do something quite
different which is i teach
um actually i mean i'm teaching like
a full-time load but it's a part-time
thing then i have my
my speaking and consulting and
philosophical counseling and tutorials
which is all you know either
organizations or or
individual clients and then i have you
know things like youtube where i get
i get some ad revenue but i'll tell you
what that's not paying the bills
uh youtube used to be a really viable
there was a time when you'd like look at
your revenues and they're getting bigger
and bigger and bigger and then there was
this
this slump that happened years and years
back
and all the people who were like
full-time dependent on youtube for their
income were like
this is the end of the world and i was
like
well it went down from you know a peak
of 400 bucks a month to like you know
100 bucks a month still making a little
bit on it
you know that's that's not where the
bulk of the money comes from so
it's it's kind of tough out there you
know um
[Music]
it would be it's it's a it's a hard
market to break into i would say for for
younger people
um youtube was kind of cool this is a
little bit of a side note youtube was
kind of cool when it
first happened because it was like a
great equalizer
you know you could put your content
there and if people thought it was any
good it would it would kind of rise to
the top
it's a lot harder to do that now to
break into it because
not only are there a lot of people out
there doing stuff but youtube's
algorithms have changed and you know
they're much more
oriented towards making as much as they
can off of
everybody um even if you don't have your
content monetized they're monetizing
your content right
so it's kind of a
it's tough to to to break in i think on
youtube for a lot of people
all right um
private name nominalism is often blamed
for inflicting damage on catholic belief
yet the term can be interpreted in many
different ways
what impact on faith did nominalist
ideas have in the late middle ages
um i mean are you asking me do i think
nominalism is the boogie the boogie man
like a lot of narratives make it out to
be and william of ockham was basically
the devil who ruined everything
i don't really think that's the case uh
i mean the church has always been
it's entire history it's been in a mess
right i was talking about
this with somebody uh just just a couple
days ago and i had this metaphor i said
you know
if if the church is the body of christ
it's a body that's always
you know like one step away from cancer
and has all sorts of oozing sores that
need to be tended to
and typically that you know the the
attention is getting put on to other
parts of the body that aren't are doing
just fine
and you know when you read church
history it's always been like that it's
just different ways in which things
happen
did nominalism help to do a number on
on some things and promote um
[Music]
modes of thinking that probably weren't
helpful yeah i guess you could say
that's the case you know
um but if it wasn't that it'd be some
other issue and nominalism
isn't like radically new in the thir you
know the
the 1300s you've got it coming up with
rosalind who anselm is combating you've
got it coming up to a certain degree
with abelard i would say you know
so yeah all right
uh ezra asked how fluent am i in
german latin greek french etc i mean i
can
i can more or less get by with french if
i if i need to
i mean for reading i can just pick up
stuff and read it generally unless i
don't know the vocabulary which
which does change uh and then i can go
get my big robin
right my dictionary uh german not not as
fluent in it um the last time i was in a
german-speaking country it took me about
a week to get myself back to the
facility of conversing with shop people
and stuff like that
um but you know
when you lay down a solid foundation
it's there in the back your mind
i'm not i'm not like fluent in
conversational stuff with
classical greek or latin because i don't
talk with people with those i
i read them and you know sometimes you
have to go and consult the grammar
each author that you read has usually
new vocabulary that you need to learn
so i don't know how it would how i would
emphasize it
but not emphasize so you can tell i'm
sick
how i would evaluate it right
friso says what's my favorite type of
pizza
um that's a good question
you know we have a really good pizza
place here in
in um milwaukee called ian's pizza
and it's milwaukee thin crust pizza you
know there's all these different styles
of pizza
uh you know the new york pizza and
chicago pizza well you know the
traditional
uh pizza here is is a very nice
yeasty thin crust and they do it really
well
and we when we order from them
usually we get for me this thing that's
called the maui wowie which is
uh ham pineapple and uh
um jalapenos so that's pretty good but i
like all their other stuff too i mean
not
there's not a lot of pizzas that i won't
eat you know except the weird crap where
it's not really pizza like if it's
supposed to be uh barbecue buffalo wings
i'm like just give me the wings don't
put them on a pizza you know
um but the traditional pizzas i i
probably i like them all you know
um andrew says have you ever gotten
something philosophically brilliant from
a source not meant to be portraying it
that you meaning not not doing
philosophy
yeah it happens all the time you know in
in reading literature
that that's probably you know something
that is the raymond carver i've been
reading a lot of
lately raymond carver the you know the
humphrey bogart
character um marlow
uh all of his his stories have marlo
right
and uh you know there's some quips in
there where you're like oh man that's
that's interesting to think about
um so that that's pretty good
um wisco simple says uh
if you were to study a different
medieval philosopher
every month for a year which 12 would
you choose i don't know i mean
that's that's one of those questions
where you'd have to like to really do it
well you'd have to like like
you know think it through a lot
obviously you know uh
augustine boethius uh anselm
aquinas would be in there you know um
probably bernard of clerval because he's
kind of interesting
you know um who else irregina so now
we're up to
six uh alcuin has got some interesting
stuff and hardly anyone ever teaches him
um i mean who else you know
once we get into like the the 12th
century there's like
an explosion of people that we we could
pick and everyone that you pick you're
like oh i'm leaving this guy out
probably would do abelard right um
stupid that we don't have any eloise's
stuff because she was pretty brilliant
maybe
as brilliant as abelard was and um
bonaventure probably you know um
i mean i probably would have my students
read scotus and oakland even though
i'm not i'm not super stoked about them
uh john a poinso maybe i don't know i
i'd have to think about it a lot i am
going to be teaching a medieval
philosophy class
two semesters from now um at carthage
college
but i don't think we'll get to even 12
philosophers over the course of the
semester
you know all right uh
surround says would you say
that reading works in original language
enhances your understanding
yeah of course um i don't know that it's
like absolutely essential
you know fortunately we do have
translators i mean if i had to read
stuff
if i could only focus on stuff that i
can read in the original
that would narrowly restrict my my
capacity to read and teach
like this semester i'm having one of my
classes
reading um selections from confucius's
analects and the menses
and uh the dao da jing and
um the drongza you know and i don't i
don't read classical chinese i mean
the most i ever got to when i was
studying chinese was being able to
read about 200 characters in modern
chinese
and classical chinese that's a whole
different ball game
i have to rely on translations you know
just like those of you who don't read
latin have to rely on translations for
reading and some
it's not it doesn't like totally cut off
our capacity to understand
all right
um
sam quick your interpretation views on
mctaggart's
unreality of time um
[Music]
i don't know it's been a long time since
i've read mctaggart so i don't really
have any views
same thing about altus there you know
i'm not i read altus here back in grad
school and and haven't
bothered since so i'm not really that
that interested um
in his works and ideas
um let's see here uh you guys see
somebody who's like
jamming up the stream with way too many
um postings
so i gotta remove him all right
ismet asks any turkish
philosophers you've come across with so
far i i don't think so i mean
unless there's somebody who turns out to
be turkish i i don't think i've actually
read
uh any turkish philosophers um
all right um
reedy nietzsche discarded his birth of
tragedy himself as you said so how is it
still relevant and how is birth of
tragedy influence literature and
philosophy well
how's it influence literature and
philosophy all you got to do is a little
bit of googling and you'll figure that
out
real quick it had massive influence
mostly by getting things wrong because
people love that idea of the apollonian
and the dionysian
you know from about 19 you know
1900 onward there is an explosion of
stuff about nietzsche
um and so what if nietzsche discarded
the birth of tragedy he didn't discard
it by the way
he criticized it he just didn't like say
everything in here is crap
there's a lot of great stuff in there
it's it's early work a lot of it's still
relevant some of the key themes are
formulated there that show up later on
you know you want to avoid all or
nothing perspectives on these
these sorts of things right
um quiet philosophy little peep was
deeply informed by augustine through his
grandfather taught philosophy at harvard
i guess i'll i'll have to take your word
for that right i don't know
um
elijah what wisdom would you recommend
for having to
trust for people again similar to how
eliot this is in brothers karamazov
trusts people
i don't know that you want to trust
people as much as alyosha does
is that is that the model that you want
to have
um i mean you should think about your
reasons for
mistrusting people and whether they are
rationally founded
or whether you've gotten yourself locked
into a
point of view that's actually creating
problems for you
and holding you back from living a good
life you know that's what i would say
and there's a lot of there's a lot of
philosophical techniques that you could
do
with that i mean part of it would be
attending to your own self-talk and like
making
you might write things down make them
explicit for yourself so
journaling could be helpful for that
all right um
man aaron lopez asks
hegel's preface in the phenomenology
says truth can be found in a discipline
only if it's engendered by philosophy
how can say a biologist be conscious
that they advance the discipline through
philosophy so
there's a couple ways you could answer
this any discipline insofar as it
reflects on its own activity and does so
in a thoughtful way is kind of doing
philosophy
that's why we have you know so often
peop students will ask questions like in
economics and the economist
at a certain point will get pissed off
and they'll be like you need to get out
of here and go to the philosophy
department where they ask these
these kinds of questions and then they
find a philosophy economics class
and then they they get into that um
i mean obviously hegel doesn't think
that truth is
only available in a discipline
if it's engendered by philosophy there's
truth in all sorts of trivial ways like
you know
do you need to actually go into a
philosophy to find out that this bottle
is you know
what a third filled with water no so
that's a true thing
but you can think of it as like
the full significance of what the
discipline is doing
has to be engendered or informed by
philosophy to some degree right but you
don't stop being a biologist
by becoming a philosopher's if you cross
some sort of invisible
line you know all right
uh dolette do you think do you think
sharon
has any philosophically interesting
ideas i'm sure he does but i i haven't
read him so
you know one of those people who's
always on my list but i never
never get to um
all right
bruno says wish you a quick recovery
thanks bruno
that's very nice of you um
let's see who else we've got that we
haven't gotten to before
[Music]
um
elijah what aspects of hegel's
christianity do you retain
i'm not a hegelian by the way so
listen do you do i retain uh i i i don't
follow hagel down that path so it's kind
of a moot point but
do i agree with hagel's defining trust
as the unity of wisdom plus power his
defining power is some of all
contradiction
um yeah i mean
anytime that you think hegel's defining
something he's probably not uh you got
to be kind you got to be kind of careful
with
with that that term definition when it
comes to hegel
all right um
james got a good question here i was
wondering
what you thought about being a
philosopher in the modern world without
being a professor
so this goes back to what i was saying
before about you know like jobs and
stuff like that
uh it's perfectly possible to be a
philosopher
without being a professor you know um
prime examples of people who did this
are people been asking about spinoza
that was his case right um you know
cicero um great philosopher in many
respects somebody i
look up to by the way highly valued in
the early modern period
politician legislator um
reader and other things not a not a
professional teacher
um descartes got to teach a little bit
most of the time he wasn't right uh we
could go on and on and on and and it's
possible to do it today
you just have to have some sort of like
way of of you know
structuring your life so that you're
getting in the things that you need like
plenty of study time
and you can you can do writing if you
want without being in the academy
there's nothing that says that you have
to try to go through the stupid
eye of the needle whole you know thing
to publish
academic articles to be taken seriously
by people i mean we have all these
wonderful platforms
where you can do great work and publish
your stuff
all you want and nowadays
self-publishing
you know 30 years ago it was viewed as
like oh you self-published that
nowadays it's more like oh man you
self-published that that's good you
didn't jump through all the stupid hoops
that
they would have made you do and like cut
out the best parts of your work
uh whether it's an academic press or or
a you know traditional
uh press um and you're gonna make all
the well not all the money amazon will
make a lot of the money or whoever you
whoever else you self-publish with
you're going to make some of the money a
lot more than you would in royalties
from from you know
harper or you know penguin or whoever
um so it's yeah it's very feasible and
the other thing i'll say about it
i think it's important to cultivate
networks
of people who you can bounce your ideas
off of and and you know engage with
and develop friendships you know
so it's it's it's feasible it's doable
but you gotta you know
you gotta look for it you gotta so for
example here in milwaukee right
we have when we're not in covid times we
have the
society of philosophers in america
chapter which is a national organization
we have a milwaukee chapter
and we meet monthly we have a milwaukee
stoic fellowship here we have a radio
show that i'm
one of the co-hosts of wisdom for life
on river west community radio you can
hear it later today
4 p.m central time is when it airs right
um there's all you know there's all
sorts of other things we're putting on
public events
you have to try to find those things and
connect with them and you can go to
university events even if you don't
belong to that university
so like you know obviously in times of
covet it's a little bit different
but in covid times a lot of these things
are also online too so you can find
those
and and participate in them
all right um frida says please talk
about the
the the point of the wax example in
descartes second meditation
it's about substance what what is the
substance it's it's an extended
substance not the
um sensible properties that we we see
there's that that part of it and then
descartes also this is really important
he says
how do we cognize this how do we
apprehend this
it's not through the senses it's not
through the imagination
it's through the the intellect all right
so that's that's the point of it
um let me scroll down
um
here we go jimmy says how do you
envision the debate of utopianism from
this decade beyond
um i don't know what the debate of
utopianism is so i i can't really
say much about that um
all right i'm gonna try to grab or we're
eight minutes away from
when this has to end i'm pretty
surprised i made it this far
but i'm gonna have to get some some
lunch after this and then get ready for
my philosophy chat for patreon
supporters
in just a few minutes um so i'm gonna
grab some random things
uh or ones that are easy to tackle i'm
gonna start actually at the bottom and
try to do people who haven't had a
chance to
get something answered before um
all right um
here's a good question this is from
dolette do you think
anti-theism can be a respectable
position to argue for or is it always
somewhat rooted in disrespect and
ignorance of the theist faith
perspective
that's a great question i think a lot of
times it is
it is rooted in like people working out
their emotional needs and stuff like
that
um and very often it's like somebody
grew up in a conservative faith
background they rejected that they swung
way over to the other extreme and
they're like a secular crusader
um i would say a lot of the new atheism
stuff is not particularly new or
particularly good
and a lot of it's just kind of snark and
you know silly [ __ ]
sort of like trying to score points that
said that's not all atheists right
um there's uh there's plenty of good
stuff out there that i think is quite
quite uh interesting and intelligent and
proper you know it could could be
properly engaged with and some of it is
in written form and some of it is in the
form of
atheists who aren't [ __ ] you know so
that's yeah that's a good question
all right um
[Music]
grayson asks a really interesting
question here
do i think a minor in philosophy with a
major in economics
is enough preparation for a master's
degree in philosophy
yes and no there are places that will
take you in like when i was in graduate
school we had a guy who came into the
master's program
and his bachelor's was in english so
they made him take some
400 level classes essentially like
remedial classes
you know like on metaphysics and sort of
a 400
level ethics class and they made him
they made him do that stuff because they
wanted him to catch up and so i think a
program that would accept you would
probably
have you do that um obviously the more
that you read the better off you are i
would say right
um all right let me scroll up a bit more
see what else we got
oh here's an here's another interesting
one from
aaron um my work
your work right my work allows folks
like myself who can't financially access
doctoral level studies in the academy to
access content contained within
do you think the insulated academy will
ever open itself up
yes and no right let's
let's forget about talking about the
academy as if it's all one
block we have over 2 000
institute institutions here in the
united states
that um you can you can go to that are
colleges or universities right so
they're all different from each other
the composition of departments makes a
big difference you can generalize and
say that
for the most part academics like pretty
much everybody in every other field
including including fields where they
talk about innovation
are pretty um you know
uh we do things this way and this is
always brought up kind of
kind of conservative not in the
political sense but in the workplace
sense people
right and they don't do a lot of
innovative thinking even the people who
talk about innovation
are very often not very innovative at
all
um will it open up it'll open up at
points right will it ever open up as
like a totality no
no i don't think so i think and a lot of
um
academic institutions quite frankly are
probably circling the drain are probably
going to
die off within the next 10 20 years
um or we're gonna have to you know like
reconsider how much
support we provide to them if they're
state schools or things like that
um so
at the same time there will always be
this other sector like what we're
talking about here
or what we're doing here where
you can get let's call it uh
you know i'm sort of again kind of
fuzzy-headed i'm thinking about like
in cooking you can get restaurant-grade
stuff right and you can buy it wholesale
and you can cook in your own kitchen
it's like that with philosophy you can
get you know
what do we want to call it academy grade
uh philosophy
and and people will provide it to you
and then you have to do a lot more of
the
the work on your end right um
all right um
oh here's a good one from noah
who is my favorite early church father
[Music]
clement of alexandria definitely clement
followed by lactancias
um those are those are probably my
favorite and then i do like john cassian
he's just kind of a he's a bit mopey you
know
um
let's see so here's from made of clay i
get confused on
what analytical and continental
philosophy
is the university's focus on one more
than the other does it matter hope this
is a good enough question
so analytic philosophy and continental
philosophy they both don't name
one single thing they name like a whole
tradition
of things and they are opposed to each
other and then there's all sorts of
other ways of doing philosophy as well
like you know philosophy is a way of
life history of philosophy
comparative philosophy classical
american philosophy
so there's all these other alternative
things
most philosophy departments in the
united states
and i guess you could say really in the
english-speaking world are going to be
either
largely analytic or largely continental
but there's exceptions like i went to
one that was for graduate school it was
pluralist in that we had you know
representatives of analytic
representatives of continental
representatives of classical american
philosophy
and even some historians of philosophy
and
for until he got fired from being a
complete
latch uh a uh person who was doing
comparative philosophy
um so you know you can look at
departments and you can like see what
they're interested in
does it matter yeah it matters because
if you want to study hegel or nietzsche
and you're going to go to an analytic
school you're probably
not going to be all that happy with what
you get you know
likewise if you really really want to
study you know
possible world semantics don't go to a
continental school you know go to an
analytics school for that
all right let me find one more thing
that i can go out on
let's see here
um
oh so here's a good one um
kevin what do you think of recent
attempts to cancel and he put in quotes
air subtle because of his views on
slavery so i i think that they're
misguided and stupid in a number of ways
and i think that the complaints about it
are also misguided and stupid in a
number of ways
you're not going to cancel aristotle
what you're going to take his work away
he's dead
he's been around forever and you know
taking his name off of a few syllabi
is not canceling him hell you can if you
want to study aristotle you can you know
watch my videos including
the one about politics book one where
he's talking about
slavery right uh and we have to be
careful about
what were aristotle's actual views on
slavery well one of them was that most
slavery is actually wrong
and based on force rather than on nature
you know um so you know you want to be
pretty
pretty careful about um what his views
on slavery were to get them right in the
first place
to be honest you know a lot of
aristotle's ideas were taken out of
context
and used for you know southerners in in
pre-civil war america and actually
afterwards too the racists down there
who unfortunately there's plenty of them
up here as well to justify
uh slavery and it was also used to
justify enslaving the native americans
within the um
you know portuguese and spanish speaking
areas
of of south america but that's not the
same thing as
aristotle that's that's shitty ver you
know
views and versions of aristotle that
people should be ashamed of
having used just to back themselves up
and so you know a lot of these these
things are based on kind of crappy
history
so aristotle's views on slavery were
considerably nuanced
and people who are worried about
aristotle getting cancelled
i mean most of what people call cancel
culture is a fiction and a boogeyman
you know people who complain about being
canceled if you're complaining about
being canceled
and you're doing so on social media or a
news program
you're not canceled and if you're
concerned about somebody else
having been canceled and you bring them
up and they're on a news program
they're not cancelled so a lot of this
this cancel culture you know stuff
you people have heard me say this before
i think is is pretty much
silly nonsense um
it doesn't appear to have you know
changed an awful lot of courses or
syllabi's
um i'm teaching aristotle this very
semester
in how many classes uh one
two uh three classes
so he hasn't been canceled here
i i think a lot of this is kind of kind
of uh people
allowing it's sort of like a what they
call a moral panic right
is is what it is so all right i am going
to
bring this to a close is about it for um
oh isaiah has one last question what's
the connection in hegel and aristotle's
master slave dialectic
no connection there don't don't try to
bring aristotle
into um hegel to understand the master
slave dialectic there is no connection
there
um and i think anybody who is trying to
claim that there is is probably selling
you something all right
so i'm gonna end it on that and uh
hopefully all of you have a good day and
i'm gonna try to
get some lunch real quick before i gotta
get on to
my philosophy chat um glad all of you
contributed these these questions
and we also do have the hegel party
tomorrow um
those of you who would like to attend
that it's going to be like this but
we're celebrating
the transition from the spirit section
of the work to the
religion section of the work anybody who
wants to come in on that i'll talk a
little bit about it we'll have a little
toast and then
you know we'll hang out